LELAND:  THE WHITE HOUSE
CORONAVIRUS TASK FORCE WRAPPING
UP ITS BRIEFING MINUTES AGO.
BEHIND ME ON CAPITOL HILL,
SENATE NEGOTIATORS ARE TRYING TO
AGREE ON A BILL THAT WOULD GIVE
TRILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO
AMERICANS AMID THE GROWING
ECONOMIC FALLOUT OF THE
CORONAVIRUS OUTBREAK.
WITH THAT, WE BRING IN
DEMOCRATIC CALIFORNIA
CONGRESSMAN, FRIEND FRIEND OF TH
JOHN GOOD AFTERNOON MEN GARAMEND
WHAT IS YOUR UNDERSTANDING OF
THE TIMELINE FROM NEGOTIATIONS
THAT ARE ONGOING NOW TO WHEN
AMERICANS WHO HAVE BEEN LAID OUT
MIGHT SEE MONEY IN THEIR
CHECKING ACCOUNT?
>> PROBABLY THAT TIMELINE, THE
LEGISLATIVE TIMELINE WILL BE
THIS WEEK, SOMETIME -- EXCUSE
ME, NEXT WEEK, MID-WEEK
PROBABLY.
HOW QUICK THOSE CHECKS WILL GO
OUT TO BE DETERMINE, PROBABLY A
FEW WEEKS AFTER THAT.
HOPEFULLY IT’S GOING TO BE VERY,
VERY FAST.
HOWEVER, IMMEDIATELY AVAILABLE
TO THE PEOPLE THAT ARE LAID OFF
IS THE UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
PROGRAM AND QUITE POSSIBLY FOR
SMALL BUSINESS, BUSINESS
INTERRUPTION INSURANCE, ASSUMING
WE CALCULATE THIS AS NOT AN ACT
OF GOD.
LELAND:  REAL QUICK FOR YOU IN
CALIFORNIA, YOUR WHOLE STATE IS
OF EFFECTIVELY UNDER A SHELTER
IN PLACE, SHELTER AT HOME.
WHAT EFFECT IS THIS HAVING ON
YOUR CONSTITUENTS.
EXPLAIN TO PEOPLE THAT ARE NOT
IN THE THREE STATES THAT ARE
EFFECTIVELY LOCKED DOWN WHAT
IT’S LIKE.
>> WELL, AN EXAMPLE, I’M DOING
THIS FROM MY HOME.
ACTUALLY, AT MY RANCH AND WE SET
UP THIS VIDEO STUDIO, IF YOU
WILL.
ALL ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, PEOPLE ARE DOING
THEIR VERY BEST TO STAY HOME, TO
NOT BE OUT AND ABOUT.
IT HAS ENORMOUS DISRUPTION ON
BUSINESS AND OBVIOUSLY ON
INDIVIDUALS.
FOR MY FAMILY AND I THINK MOST
OTHER FAMILIAR FAMILIES, I WAS H
THE STUDIO.
AS I WAS LEAVING THE RANCH MY
DAUGHTER WAVED ME DOWN AND SAID
WHERE DO YOU THINK YOU’RE GOING.
I SAID I’M GOING TO THE STUDIO.
SHE SAID NO, YOU’RE NOT, GET
HOME.
THAT’S PRETTY GOOD ADVICE.
LELAND:  FOR 50 PLUS YEARS
YOU’VE BEEN LISTENING TO HER,
IT’S WORKED OUT PRETTY WELL SO
FAR.
WE APPRECIATE YOUR TIME,
CONGRESSMAN.
SORRY WE HAVE TO CUT IT A BIT
SHORT.
WE’LL HAVE YOU BACK EITHER NEXT